i' never
been the quizzes yeah what if is it bad
for you if I don't pick up my quiz
because I have your Solutions I have the
grade on bright space I'll tell you why
I'd like you to pick it up because
otherwise it's become
Rec so you
PR over number
raise it up a couple points you
know with
AI I will pick it up
okay
folks uh I want to start by I I'm not
going to pick on you guys but there are
two interrelated problems that came out
after the quiz one is I think I
mentioned I wanted you to write the name
on the back right or am I imagining this
right about half of you did not which
led to a second problem which is when
you look through the quizzes if half the
quizzes have no last name you're having
trouble finding your name because you
don't know where you are in the alphabet
which led to a problem around 11:30 at
night last night I got an email from
somebody I don't know what they were
doing in the building at that time they
said I can't find my quiz and they're
all out of
order I actually made a trip out at
11:30 no I live right across the so
kind of tough to get into this building
after 11:30 they convince the security
guard that I was not a threat and I went
up and I resorted the quizzes and then
this morning again they were out of
order you know this is um I think we
know if we and part of the reason for
that if you don't is that last so next
time next Quiz when I ask you to write
your name on the back please do there's
one quiz that had not even a last name
it had just initial
I don't know whether you think your
initials are somehow unique but putting
in initials is a terrible way to tell me
who you are right it's a class of 300
you put two two initials there I have no
idea who you are now in algebra what's
the rule if you have one
equation you can have one
unknown I have more than one unknown
because there are 12 or 13 people who
didn't take the quiz and now I don't
know where to put you so this is just
for the next Quiz write your name on the
back and for God's sakes please don't
mess with my alphabetical order when
you're picking your quiz up because you
know I know it's it's tough to sometimes
find your quiz you've turned it over
you're going backward but leave it back
the way it was when you're done cuz it
makes everybody else's job a little
easier okay so today we
have the next step in intrinsic
valuation right so remind me again where
we are we've talked about discount rates
cost of capital we've talked about cash
flows free cash The Firm free cash FL
Equity we've talked about growth rates
and we put closure with the terminal
value that's it right that's
DCF and when you discount cash flows
back at the cost of capital you come up
with the value of the business and then
you got to get from there to a value per
share for your company for the next
session or two that's all we're going to
talk about how once you come up with the
value of the business you get from there
to value per
share I call these the loose ense in
valuation because you don't pay much
attention to them because you think
you're done
so let's talk a little bit about the
lead into these loose
sets every one of your companies has a
cash balance right if you're doing a
firm valuation that cash balance sits to
the side while you're valuing the
business it's a free cash flow you
discounted the cost of capital and the
rule is at the end of the
process you add the cash balance on to
your value because it's not been counted
yet so I'm going to present to you an
argument I've heard from analysts as to
why cash balances hurt the value of a
company and you tell me whether there's
any basis to this so an analyst says
look you know Apple has 200 billion
dollar in cash and it does the cash is
invested right now earning about
45% that's well below Apple's cost to
Capital and what Apple earns on on its
other projects and he says that makes
cash a bad
investment using that definition cash is
a bad investment then for most companies
what is the analyst Miss is saying this
is
actually quote I pulled from
an don't wait it and look at our
reinvestments we look at non but that
still doesn't address the main question
right is know basic statement is a true
one the return on Capital on cash is
much lower than the cost of
capital but there's a much more direct
way to answer that question too I think
you're on to it op opportunity cost
what's the opportunity cost of an
investment is what you can make on
another investment but complete the the
sentence of equivalent risk right what's
cash invested in something liquid and
riskless the the question always ask
people is if you have cash in your
brokerage account and I do so 3 days ago
I know I do this mopping up from me and
my kids
and this cash sitting around and I took
the cash and I put it into six Monon
Tes liquid hopefully
riskless why hopefully who knows what
the US Treasury might do I made about 4
and a half% what did I say Apple's
making on its cash about 4 and a
half% you're earning a low rate of
return but a fair rate of return if you
earn what I would earn on a table you're
effectively earn it's a zero Net Present
Value investment cash earns a low return
but it's not a bad investment today
we're going to ask a followup question
are there times where you might discount
cash in the hands of a company but it's
got nothing to do with cash earning low
rates of return that's okay second and
this is more a test of your accounting
let's see how many of you understand or
remember your accounting companies often
own pieces of other companies big or
small pieces so let's say company a owns
60% of Company
B right
and you take do a valuation of company a
you take the earnings the cash flows you
come up with the valuation of company
a how much of Company B is in that
value you see what my question is you
got free cash for the firm cost of
capital how much of
company 100% you're saying that makes no
sense I agree but what is it about the
way accounting is done that leads 100%
to be
counted many Financial control another
company you have to consolidate you have
to consolidate you have to act like you
own 100% I've never understood this this
one another one of those things in
accounting I don't quite get I want six
I want 60% you're making me count as if
I have 100% what that means is if you
value this company a all the way through
you've overvalued your ownership stake
in Company B right so to get back to
your value what do you need to
do you counted 100% you own only 60% you
got to take out the 40% that doesn't
belong to you is there an accounting
word for that 40% that doesn't belong to
you it is it's called non-controlling or
a minority interest we're going to talk
about how to deal with that because in
effect you've double counted
otherwise let's change the scenario a
little bit let's suppose you own 10% or
5% of another company and you do the
same thing you value company a all the
way through how much of Company B is in
there clear
I would like you to be tell you're
thinking like somebody with common sense
think like an accountant for a little
while not that accountants don't have
common sense but perhaps they don't you
know when you own 10% of a company what
you're required to do you're required to
keep it out of your financials and after
you've done your operating income below
the operating income you bring in the
10% so when you value a company with a
lot of minority Holdings in other
companies 5% 10% and you do a discounted
cash flow valuation you value none of
those cross Holdings
cross Holdings are the are the component
of valuation that almost everybody in
this class struggles with so in the
second quiz is a cross-holding question
through history it's a question where
people have trouble because sometimes
you're adding it back because you
haven't counted it sometimes you're
subtracting things out sometimes you're
doing both and as counting gets Messier
and Messier and how it deals with cross
Holdings this problem is only going to
grow so we'll come back and talk more
about cross Holdings today in the class
so let me open up to the section I know
you've lost your way in the slide so
I'll tell you where we are in the packet
we're on slide
219 called tying up loose sets basically
it's about dealing with the fact that
you tell me you're done and then you do
all these things that actually
undercut do you know how Academia
works I'll tell you how it works I work
like four and a half hours a week
incredibly
for about 15 weeks a
year I get the remaining 37 weeks
off and because I work so hard I get
every seventh year off with pay it's
like very biblical you work six days you
get the seventh day off don't let any
Professor tell you how difficult their
life is can't get any cushier than
this so I've had because I've been
teaching a long time five sabatical you
measure academic life in the number of
sabatical you've had this is about two
sabatical ago notice how already I'm
framing not 14 years ago but two
sabatical
ago sabatical is coming up and usually
people have big plans for their
sabatical they're going to write a book
or do do research or go to another
University and this particular sabatical
had a singular objective I wanted to
have nothing to do for a whole
year the sabatical first day happens I'm
a little ostentatious about the whole
thing I go to the local office supplies
store and I get one of those to-do
things you can put on the wall I bring
it home I put it right above the little
cubicle area where I worked at at home
and these were this was when all four of
my kids were still at home going to
school so they all come down on their
way to school and I point to my to-do
list and say kids have nothing to do
today piss them off no
end but they went off to school and then
I made my fatal mistake my wife came
down the stairs and said H have nothing
to do today she said really why don't
you take the dog for a walk take the dog
for a walk I come back there's something
on my to-do list I'm foiled again it
says pick up bok
choy at the grocery store I'll make a
confession I had no idea what bok choy
was I was too embarrassed to ask I spent
about 45 minutes wandering around say
Seafood not there meat ultimately turns
out ugly looking cabbage I find it I
come back home there's another item on
my to-do list pick up kids from school
and after about the third or fourth item
I'm getting desperate I want to do
something to keep my wife off my to-do
list to show how desperate I get I get
an email from a magazine or editor of a
magazine called CFA magazine a magazine
I never heard of and he says would you
write an article for us my first
reaction was I'm un sabatical I want
nothing to do but then I remembered I
needed things to do to keep my wife off
the list so I said okay and then I write
in big letters on the to-do list write
CFA article cannot pick up Bo kids etc
etc and I did write the article I have
to tell you the only thing I've ever
written in valuation that's got me hate
mail you know how difficult it is to get
hate mail in this business people don't
write say I hate you for using bottom up
Bas or I hate you for you they don't
feel strongly enough part of the reason
I got the hate mail was the title for
the article it said stop the
garnishing and I was talking about this
practice and valuation we valued a
company and then you added 30% for
control and 50 % for this and you
knocked off 25% for liquidity and by the
time you were done you came back to the
number you wanted to in the first place
and they said you got to stop that and I
might have used the word arbitrary to
describe the premiums and discounts
which pissed off a lot of
people it's not arbitr it's based on
restricted stock studies or whatever
other crap they looked at but one of the
emails actually know went beyond the
insult face and said if you don't like
the way we're doing these things in
valuation why don't you come up with a
the better way do you have a point I
said I have 11 months in my sabatical
here's what I'm going to do each month
I'm going to pick up what I call a loose
ENT and I'm going to say if I were able
to Value this how would I do it month
one was UN control month two was in a
liquidity so basically each month so my
plans to do absolutely nothing on my
sabatical kind of fell apart but it
became one half of one of my valuation
books the last half the second half of
the modor valuation is that sabatical
playing out so I'm going to take you on
a speedy run of those 11 months and talk
about some of the things I had to deal
with in terms of coming up with you know
a lose sens so I'm going to start with
cash and marketable securities right we
know what every textbook asks you to do
just don't play games with it the 100
million cash just add the 100 million on
I'm going to ask what I think is a
provocative question are there companies
where you see a 100 million in cash in
the hands of that company where you
might actually value that cash at less
than 100 million and conversely other
companies were so basically 100 million
cash you might attach a discount or
premium what are the conditions under so
I want you to start thinking about that
because that's where we're going to
start second I'm going to talk about
cross Holdings in a perfect world how
would you Value Cross
Holdings and then we're going to talk
about the real world and the the
information limitations we have and talk
about how to Value Cross Holdings so you
got the value of the firm discounted
cash flow value add cash and you got a
cross Holdings and you look around say
is there anything else I should be
adding on this is your last chance to
bring in other stuff what else can you
add on to a discounted cash flow
valuation I'll give you a preview you're
a hotel company you value the company as
a hotel company can I add the real
estate on which the hotel sits to my
valuation start thinking about it
because again I want that's going to be
something we're going to have to come to
deal with because companies often have
physical assets other assets what can I
add on what should I not add on and
what's the rule that I use once I come
up with the value of the firm I have to
subtract our debt right did we have to
deal with what is debt earlier in the
valuation in the context of estimating a
cost of capital right this is a
different question what do I net out
from the value of the firm and maybe the
rules are going to get a little
different here because this is my last
chance to bring in anything else that
worries me like what maybe there's a
lawsuit hanging over the company or if I
lose the lawsuit there's a small chance
it could wipe out half the company this
is your last chance for those lose sents
then once you value the equity to get to
value of equity per share the routine
when I first wrote my first addition you
got the value of equity value of equity
per share was trivial you divide by the
number of shares the world has become a
Messier Place why because increasingly
companies use equity to compensate
employees either as options or with
restricted stock either creates an issue
the for of more of an issue issue than
the latter cuz I can't just divide by
the number of shares I got to deal with
those Equity options and restricted
stock to come up with the value per
share those are the loose heads let's
get the process rolling let's start with
the value of cash the rule again every
textbook is you have cash don't mess
with it just add it on count it more
carefully if you want if it's currency
but it's cash is cash and we're
incredibly sloppy about the way we deal
with cash and valuation if you ask what
do you do with cash they have no idea
just slip through it if you do an equity
valuation where you as to take dividend
discount model cash kind of dissipates
disappears somewhere in the game right
so where did it
go so I'm going to start off with a very
simplistic example and I want you to
help me figure out with the with the
example that I've given why cash might
matter in a company so I'm going to show
you three
companies they all have a 100 million in
cash so there's no doubt about the cash
being there so it's not you know
fictional cash it's actual real cash
$100 million but here's where they're
different company a has historically
earned a return on capital of 10% its
cost of capital is
10% Company B is historically earned a
return on capital of 5% its cost of
capital is 10% company C has
historically earned a 10% spread over
its cost of capital A and B are
developed Market companies C is an
Argentine
company I'm going to argue that in one
of these three companies cash is going
to be a neutral asset what does that
mean 100 million in
cash it's worth 100 million which is
what we do in every valuation in one of
these three companies you might discount
the cash in the hands of that
company and one of these three companies
you might attach a premium so you ready
which of these three companies is Cash
most likely to be a neutral asset
they earn roughly their cost of capital
it's a Blog company what does a Blog
company do it doesn't do good things it
doesn't do bad things it kind of runs in
place but before you complain about blog
companies there's a fate far worse than
investing in a blog company which is
which of the companies would you
discount the cash B and what is it about
B that terrifies you return on invest
Capital lower and let's state in
intuitive terms what does this company
have a history of doing stupid things
you're attaching a stupidity
discount you're saying these managers
are so incompetent that they will find a
way to waste the 100 minutes it's not
the cash itself that's the problem it's
what the company can do with the
cash and the more bad stuff you've done
in the past the more of a discount
you're
apply and in one of these three
companies you might actually attach a
premium and by Exception by
elimination what is it about companyc
that leads you to view the cash as a
positive
that's part of it right they take good
Investments but if you you have lots of
us companies who earn more than the cost
of capital wouldn't attach a premium to
the
cash no that's a bad reason for paying a
premium right so because then you can do
all kinds of things in the US you know
why we don't historically attach a
premium to cash is because you have
great Investments what do you assume you
can do go out and raise Capital why did
I put the the company in
Argentina any Latin Americans here
nobody wants it me to
it if I say Argentina what comes to
mind you from Argentina in fact last
time I was in Uruguay they asked me what
I thought about Argentina and I said
Argentina is having this eccentric Uncle
living in your
attic and he comes down every two or
three weeks and he's completely out of
control right that's how Uruguay lives
because right next to
Argentina Argentina is a is a market
where in the last 25 years they have at
least five or six times the capital
markets have completely shut down let me
explain what I mean by that you can't
raise Equity you can't borrow money from
a bank capital is Frozen now do you see
the advantage of having a cash balance
in a market like that one you can
survive the next Crisis you essentially
have so in an Argentina the only mistake
I made is putting in Argentina because I
did this in Brazil this this session in
Brazil once and I asked this question
know which of these three companies we
attach a discount to like 85% of the
audience picked the Argentine company I
said what's going on here turned out the
previous week you know Brazil had played
Argentina in a soccer game Brazil had
lost and they were you can't trust these
argentines so this has nothing to do
with trust it's a factor of Capital
Market so when you're in an Emerging
Market you have a cash
balance this might actually allow you to
survive and live so we're actually
arguing that the market treats cash
differently in different companies
sounds a little outlandish right so I'm
going to show you the results of of what
plays out there it's not the cash itself
that you're being punished for it's what
you do with the cash so if you have a
history of taking bad
Investments I'm essentially going to
punish you not because there's cash in
your balance sheet but because what you
might do with the cash and the worse
your history the bigger the discount is
going to be so as you look at companies
with cash balances there are good
reasons for discounting cash and bad
reasons and here's the market number
that I want to look at it's one of the
most creative re I usually don't care
much for academic research because
they're asking questions that nobody
cares what the answer is and they give
answers that only like 25 people care
about this was actually a paper that
tried to ask a big question which is how
much does the market value cash in the
hands of a company they took all us
companies and with a very clever way
they actually came up with an estimate
how much a dollar in cash is valued so
looking across all companies in the
market they found that across all firms
a dollar in cash is valued at a dollar
good news because that's what we do but
if you look at mature firms with
negative excess Returns what does that
mean negative excess returns companies
like company
b a dollar in cash is valued at 69
cents that's a mindboggling discount
think about it you have a mature company
with a bad history you have 10 billion
in cash what do I value the 10 billion
at
6.9
billion is there a let's say the
management that company calls you and
says oh we're being underpriced by the
market there is 31% Discount that
they're putting on our cash balance what
should we do what's the most direct
advice you should give
them give the C don't use the cash
that's why I'm punishing you give the
cash back to the
shareholders using the cash is actually
going to reinforce you can't tell them
earn a higher return they don't there
Inc capable of the business is not there
give the cash back you think they're
going to listen to you what are they
going to say we've
changed we're much better
now we are have activist investors right
car I can be but you know car I can's
favorite Target is a company like this
one CU what does K I can do he comes in
and he says you have 10 billion in cash
give back the cash the minute you give
that cash back the 31% discount
disappears this is activist investing we
have to do very little to get that
discount
released last week I was looking across
the world in fact this said I just
posted this on dividends and cash
balances around the world the part of
the world where you get the lowest
dividend payout is
India I'll give you contast us companies
return about 77% of their earnings
either as dividends or BuyBacks India
the typical Indian companies across all
Indian companies that ratio is
31% now some of this is for growth right
India is a big growth Market the other
is that Indian managers family group
companies like to hold the cash because
once they pay the cash out they don't
control the cash so why is the number so
high in the US what Le leads Indian us
companies return so much cash it's not
because they care about their
shareholders it's because there's this
constant pressure from activist
investors saying hey give me the cash
back you don't need the cash corporate
governance in India is essentially dead
in the water in most those
companies what does that mean these
companies are going to have big cash
balances many Are Family group companies
you don't trust the company with the
cash so guess what these companies get
priced at three times earnings four
times earnings the families complain
that they're being
underpriced but who can blame investors
for discounting the cash in the hands of
the company you need that push of
corporate governance for the cash to be
released at the other end of the
spectrum if you look at high growth
firms that earned well above the cost of
capital there's actually a premium
attached if you're a young tech company
I want you to have a cash balance why
because I Want You To Survive to deliver
on your
potential so when you look at companies
you can already see differences in how
cash gets treated based on the company
get a question the cash depend the tax
rate you can never get a dollar to an
investor right
why dividend they'll have to pay taxes
do a buy a buy back you get cap but you
you do a buyback you get capital gain
but do you get capital gains so only the
people who sell their shares back get
tax the way capital gains works is you
can defer it until you sell it so in a
sense I so I can I can reduce it but one
way or other the cash ultimately has to
get to you
right but no no matter when it gets you
there's a tax issue right so this is all
you're doing is delaying the issue you
can't make it go away so that alone
can't explain why you're holding on to
cash because ultimately you got to
figure out way to get that cash to
me it's always out of it because there
remember bulk of the money in US markets
is tax exempt Pension funds so a lot of
money is basically not driven by
taxes now I'm going to do a little
tangent question
yeah adding if you're
addre value it increases the value it
doesn't improve the value it's cash is
cash right so it's not not as if you're
doing the company a favor adding the
$200 billion to Apple's value it's not
doing them a favor it's actually
counting an asset that is the most the
easiest asset to Value
no that's basically what you would do in
a in a in apple I'm not going to put any
pressure in apple because I don't think
there's any discount on Apple that's a
good point ask why do you think Apple's
not being punished for having such a big
cash
balance that is out of it how many big
Acquisitions has Apple made in the last
years none they bought beats but I think
that was like petty cash for them a 5
billion who's going to notice 5 billion
even leaving the company have 200
billion in
cash you know how much if you think
about uh how much discipline a top
management has to have to not spend the
cash I think they put a motor on one
infinity loop to keep Bankers out right
cuz every Banker is out there saying do
I have a deal for you in the last 15
years I've seen people say that Apple
should buy Netflix Apple should buy
Tesla Apple should buy
Greece when you have 200 billion you can
buy entire countries and you got to give
Apple Credit they haven't done it and
that takes disciplines as a stockholder
what are you saying they have 200
billion cash but Tim Cook is not going
to buy some big company for 200
billion because that's not who he is
that's basically what trust is based on
is you look at a history and you say so
when companies do things that breaks the
trust you start to see discount sh three
years ago Facebook was in trouble
remember what triggered that
trouble what did Mark Zuckerberg do that
dug the company into a hole they're out
of it now we'll talk about what they've
done to get out of the hole what did he
announce with a lot of fanfare that
basically no this met the more broadly
the metaverse remember he was he told
the world he was going to spend a
hundred billion in the metaverse VR is
part of that
metaverse and people said what exactly
is the metaverse how are you going to
make money and he said I haven't thought
about it but we spend a100 billion doar
first and he was very caught up in I am
a tech guy I know what I'm doing and
markets finally said you know what we
don't trust you stock price collapsed
I'll wage a Facebook's cash balance was
being discounted then it was discounted
the point of it was actually discounted
to zero because the Assumption was they
will find a way to put this money to
this metaverse we have no idea what it
is how did Facebook get the trust back
first they walk back from the metaverse
edge so you notice that he doesn't do
this metaverse crap
anymore which is good most managers
don't listen he started returning cash
in the form of BuyBacks and that's all
management can do is listen to sherold
saying you don't trust us let me do
something to kind of earn that trust
back you you can't talk the trust back
you can't tell maners trust me you got
to do things so met is actually a great
example of trust lost and Trust regained
and how difficult it is for companies to
retain that
trust now everything I've said about
cash I can say about another group of
Investments as well cash should be an
easy asset to Value right it's right
there and I'm discounting the cash
because I don't trust you with my
cash you've all you know you you're all
familiar with mutual funds right so most
mutual funds are what are what are
called open-end funds what does that
mean you send your money to Fidelity Mel
and what they do is the fund gets larger
everybody gets an equal share of the net
or or a share based so openend funds
basically are basically money going in
invest in stocks and the net asset value
just flows through to you based on how
many shares you owe you know what a Clos
in fund is a closed in fund is a fund
where you buy shares in the fund the
fund in invest in publicly traded stock
so when you look at its balance sheet it
you'll see apple Google Microsoft Etc
because that's what they've invested in
if I ask you to value a closed in fund
this should be the easiest of all
valuations to do right every asset is
publicly traded you take the market cap
you add them all up you come up with the
value and if you divide by the share
count you should get the value per share
that the stock is trading at
right for 50 years in finance research
has come up with this what's called a
closed and fund discount what are they
talking about if you look across all
closed in funds the typical closed in
fund trades at a discount of about 15 to
20% on its net asset
value you own a $100 million of stock
publicly traded stock the fund trades at
75 80 85
million there are a few Clos in funds
that trade at
premiums but it's called a puzzle but I
don't think it's a puzzle and here's why
okay let's assume that a typical closed
in fund trades at an average risk
portfolio which is a beta one and let's
suppose the cost of equity for a beta
one risk free rate Equity risk is 11 a
half% what's a history of Active
investing that you deliver the market
return or deliver a little
less historically active investors have
delivered less than the market for
whatever reason let's say this fund
consistently delivers about a half a
percent less than it should why you got
to pay all those analysts and the people
in the building they're not adding value
it's got to come out of your
return will this how will this affect
how much you pay to invest in the fund
so you invest $100 in the fund you need
to make 11 and a half% right but you're
making only
$1 forget growth know keep growth out of
can you tell me what the what the market
value of this fund will be if you earn
$1 every ear in perpetu and your cost of
equity is
115% what's the value of perity you take
the cash flow you divide by the discount
rate right you take 11 and divide by
11.5% you get like $94 you're saying so
what there's a 6% discount on the value
the discount is being applied because
you think this manager will keep taking
Investments That earned less than the
required rate of return there's your
answer to the closed in fund discount
the closed in fund discount exists
because we don't trust closed in fund
managers to deliver the expected return
but then let's look at the few closed in
funds that trade at a premium if the
closed in fund discount is explained by
the fact that closed in fund managers
expected to underperform the market you
see what causes some closed in funds to
trade a premium you expect that manager
to beat the market must be a very
special manager right I'm going to show
you the picture of the most famous
closon fund manager on the face of the
Earth who am I talking about
guy called Warren Buffett he doesn't
it's not called a Clos in fund it's
called an insurance company Berkshire
hatway where Geo brings in capital he
invests it for the closon fund and
here's what Berkshire hatway has looked
like over its lifetime don't don't worry
about all the red the red is actually
the market cap the green if you look at
busher at's assets is all publicly
traded companies Washington Post
Coca-Cola so if you look at the green
it's a book value the market value has
been consistently above the book value
some of it can be explained by having a
really good insurance company but if you
compare the price to book ratio for
Berkshire haway with the price to book
ratio for a typical insurance company
historically busher hadway traded a
premium there's been a premium in the
closed in fund
why because you trust warrant Buffet to
earn more but that difference seems to
have you know if you go across time and
you look at the difference between
Berkshire haway and insurance companies
that difference especially as you get
over time see to be getting smaller and
in 2023 it completely disappeared
Berkshire heway now looks like a typical
insurance
company so what's happening
here he's pretty old it's exactly
mortality is reminding you you got this
reminded last year when Charlie manga
died
right I know it sounds morbid but if
you're going to see BU know Warren
Buffett at a meeting get there soon like
this year right it's in a month or so I
don't have any crystal ball I'm not
saying he's going to die next year but
in 93 the clock is ticking right maybe
he live to be 115 like that you know the
oldest person on the face of the Earth
but the market is also know know
sometimes you got to listen to what
Warren Buffett says and 10 years ago
what did he say that he wasn't going to
be the one picking stocks anymore at
bushire heway he actually turned over
the management of the fund to Todd
Colmes and Ted Wexler the two and
they're very good managers but they're
not Warren Buffett this has now become a
very average Clos fund and what do
average Clos funds do they trade at
roughly whatever you're going to see as
the assets this is now trading as a very
good insurance company without that
premium you got with
buffer so whatever we said about cash
you're going to see play out with things
like closed in funds yeah is value
Equity like Market exactly right because
it's because it's required to Mark to
Market so if you bought Coca-Cola 10 so
everything on the books is marked to
Market so one way to think about buying
bushire heway shares is you're buying
Coca-Cola and paying a 20% premium on
the stock price kind of mindboggling
when you think about it but that's what
Warren Buffett brought to the
company so any questions about the
discount premium either cash or closed
in funds you're effectively as an
investor building in that expectation
let's talk about cross Holdings as I
said this is to me the the most
difficult part of valuation because it's
so
messy step back and think about the
three ways in which accountants classify
cross Holdings if you own three four 5%
of a company and you take no role in how
the companies run it's called a minority
passive holding and with a minority
passive holding here's what you're
required to do on your income statement
you're required to show the the
dividends you received dividends you
received from that holding and on the
balance sheet you have to show what you
originally invested to get that
holding in the late 90s soft Bank was
then a young upcoming Japanese company
masaan was a much younger man than he is
today but the legend of masan was born
the day he bought Yahoo as a venture
capitalist in the early
90s and that venture capital investment
had become 70% of soft Bank by the time
you got to 199 7 he owned like 5 6 7% of
Yahoo but the stock had gone up but if
you looked at soft bank's financial
statements in
1997 that Yahoo holding was classified
as a minority passive investment so if
you look at the income statement for
soft Bank what is it what are you going
to see from the yaho holding what did I
say you have to record the dividends you
receive right you know what dividends
Yahoo is paying in the '90s zero you'd
have seen nothing you saying okay be on
the balance sheet
you go to the balance sheet you'd have
seen a $50 million investment reflecting
the original VC investment that was the
the market value was $7
billion the worst possible scenario of
course for you is minority passive
Investments because there's nothing in
the financials that's going to help
you one step up a minority active
Investments minority active investment
let's say you own 20% of a company
here's what you required to do yes
you're required to use What's called the
equity approach so in your income
statement you have to show 20 20% of the
net income or the net loss it's a little
better than dividends but below the
operating income line key is below the
operating income line and on your
balance sheet you have to show what you
originally invested plus or minus 20% of
the retained earnings in so it's like an
updated Book value not great but much
better than minority person and then you
get to the 60% holding it's classified
as a majority holding and accountants
lose their
minds own 60% you have to consolidate so
what what does that mean when you do
revenues for your company you have to
count 100% of the revenues and you say
look I own only 60% the accountant waves
you off you get to operating income you
act like you have 100% you say I own
only 60% the accountant waves you off
again you get to the asset side you
count all of the debt all of the cash
and each step you saying but I own only
60% last moment the accountant wakes up
and says you own only 60% that's what
I've been trying to tell you all this
time you don't own 40%
exactly you got to subtract it out there
in is a minority interest it's a residue
of consolidation so what's the first
thing you need to do if your company has
cross Holdings figure out how they've
been accounted for and with joint
ventures this process become even
Messier so if you see on your balance
sheet cross Holdings go to the footnotes
to see how they're accounted for they
have to tell you what the accounting
system is because only then can you even
take the next step so let's say you
figured out the accounting in a perfect
world here's how you'd Value Cross
Holdings first you'd value the parent
company standing alone you know what I
mean by parent company when you have a
Consolidated company many companies also
report what I call parent Financial
which is just the Standalone parent
company if you have those financials
value the parent company separately then
take each cross holding and value each
cross holding separately whether it's 5%
or 60% you don't care so each cross
holding you value separately as a
separate business
then you take 5% of the first one 60% of
the second one 35% and you add them all
up in the perfect world that's what I
would do I almost never get a chance to
try this out because in the real world
it's really difficult to do this because
you need full financials for each of the
subsidiaries and you have to do a full
valuation so I'll tell you when I got
closest you're all familiar with Yahoo
the company right it's now no longer a
company so you might not be familiar
with yaho is a company the name lives on
but Yahoo the company's kind of gone
moved on into the great beyond this is a
valuation I did right after Marissa
Meyer who's a what employee number 11 at
Google was brought into Yahoo and asked
to turn the company around most
dangerous thing you can do is bring in a
new SE a turn a company R and here's why
because in
2014 if you look at Yahoo's basic
operating business it had a search
engine that nobody searched
on and an email program that I think
only people over the age of 70 is called
Yahoo
mail that's a bad business it's
shrinking and only in the minds of the
fevered few was there any chance that
Yahoo is going to make a comeback and
replace Google again so I valued Yahoo
with the best possible assumptions I
could make I came up with a value of
about 4 billion for Yahoo stock was
trading at$ 39
bilon yeah that's a really overvalued
stock it wasn't because there were two
cross Holdings that Yahoo
had that effectively made up the
difference so first was a
35% of Yahoo Japan which is a standalone
company and for whatever reason the
Japanese still use Yahoo don't ask me
why and you could value it full
Financial so I was able to Value it
separately and it also owned 21% of a
then very young privately owned company
called
Alibaba which was just on the verge of
going
public and the nice thing about just
being on the verge of going public had
filed the prospectus I had full
financials this was a case where I could
do intrinsic valuations of all three
companies and I did so I valued yaho
based Core Business parent business I
valued Yahoo Japan because it's a
separate publicly traded company and
took 35% of that Equity value I value
22% of Alibaba
and that's a huge
number and you take 22% of that you add
the three numbers up you come up with
the total value of the company including
the cross Holdings I did mop up a few
loose end because if you try to sell
these cross Holdings you're going to pay
a tax CU Yahoo's investment in I took
into account the tax the value that I
got per share was about $41 adding up
the intrinsic valuations to these
companies why was I able to do it yah is
a publicly traded company at their
financials Yahoo Japan is a separate
publicly traded company at their
financials Alibaba had filed it I
couldn't have done this before the IPO
because the Alibaba numbers were kind of
diffused I didn't know what they look
like I was able to do it because at that
point in time I had access to all three
he saying why can't I do this for every
company I'll tell you a story to
illustrate how messy this process can be
late 90s I was writing the second
edition I think of my investment
valuation book there was valuing a
Japanese company and when you value
Japanese company in the 1990s you're
always teetering on the edge of disaster
why because the Japanese risk free rate
was so much lower than the risk free
rate elsewhere in the world that if you
took any of the numbers you usually use
in the rest of the world to like growth
rate in perpetuity put in a Japanese
company would blow up so I was very
careful I was very proud of myself I
finished it I'm pading myself vigorously
on the back and then I take a look at
this company's balance sheet and I wish
I had not
they
227 cross
Holdings so if I were one of these
careful analysts I'm not but if I one of
these careful analysts wanted to do
things right my job is laid out for me
right what do I have to do to Value this
one company I have to Value 228
companies and take 2% of company there's
zero chance I'm doing that to begin with
but let's say I went down that route I
would still have not been able to do it
because 60 of the companies were public
I could have done you know could have
got the the other 167 were privately
owned with zero information provided so
I call the investment relations officer
for this Japanese company it's an
incredibly intimidating lady she picks
up the phone says what do you want I
said you know what I'm valuing a company
it's not for an expose can you give me
some
information on your cross holding she
said I cannot give you that information
I said why not it's proprietary Terri if
Ying the way she said the word
proprietary so I said what if I bought a
th000 shares in your company and called
you she said still be
proprietary I said that doesn't make any
sense to me I'd be part owner of the
company you're refusing to tell me what
I
own he says you have a
point but it's still
proprietary I get ready to hang up the
phone banging my head against a brick
wall right she said wait wait I do have
something I can tell you about these
cross Holdings I said maybe she's is
going to give me some information on
revenues or earnings I said what she
said I cannot give you
specifics but these cross Holdings are
worth a
lot I said look I'm sitting here in
front of an Excel spreadsheet I a sell
right next to crosh holding I've entered
the words
lot but I seem to be getting error
messages right below can you tell me how
many zeros there are in a
lot she didn't answer but that cuts to
the heart of the Cross holding culture
right what do managers do they hold up a
brown paper bag said trust me it's full
of cash can I look in the bag no I'll
tell you how much that's what we allow
these companies to do right tell me on
tell us on a balance sheet what their
cross Holdings are worth do you really
believe soft Bank when they say their
Ola holding is worth x billion dollars I
know they got ernston young or deoy to
come in and do their work for them but
you're basically taking them at their
word so I'm going to give you some
approxim I use because there's really no
this isn't a problem with knowing what
to do the information is not
there so here's what I do when companies
have cross Holdings I know the book
value these Holdings most companies use
the equity approach if you tell me what
business you're in let's say you have a
chemical company in your cross holding
on my web page I actually have Price to
Book ratios by Industry Group let's say
the typical Chemical Company trades at
1.5 times Book value you see where I'm
going to go right you have $100 million
cross holding it's a chemical company
it's a book value I multiplied by 1.5 to
come up with he say that is so
simplistic guilty is
charged but given the information I have
it's better than using Book value I'm
adjusting the book value if your
company's publicly traded Japanese
company the 60 companies were publicly
traded I cheated you know what I used as
a value I took the market price why is
that cheating because an intrinsic value
you're supposed to question the market
price but I said look if 60 companies
think of how much time it saves me to
take take the market
price the times you have to be cautious
about cross Holdings is when you have a
cross holding that is big and a big
chunk of your company comes from that
cross holding soft B for the last
probably decade what's the biggest
holding
there like Yahoo they were an early
investor in Alibaba they 20 25% of
Alibaba which they got as a venture
capitalist for a while there a third of
soft bank's value came from the Alibaba
holding which means if you're valuing S
soft bank there's no way around the fact
that you have to Value Alibaba as well
because otherwise you're just going to
get the market price feed
through what do you think about
Microsoft's holding of open
AI right you could trust the markets
which tell you open AI could be worth
100 billion 49% of 100 billion that's a
big cross holding this isn't Penny
change you're going to have to face this
even with us companies now because know
these cross Holdings can show
up so in the approximation game you're
basically pricing cross Holdings so I
actually took Yahoo and I said if I
didn't want to do an intrinsic valuation
I were too lazy I could price Yahoo the
parent company applying a multiple I use
the Enterprise Value sales multiple and
basically the only reason I use EV to
sales is it's kind of less affected by
accounting and I have a US company a
Japanese company and a Chinese company
in my mix I'm worried about whether the
Abit and the abbit are comparable so
back of the envelope much easier to do
an intrinsic valuation but you're
pricing the three pieces there to come
up with the pricing of the company the
case of yaho turned out to give me a
answer very similar to my intrinsic
valuation but the answers could have
been very different so any questions on
Cross
Holdings which brings me to Mo up so you
valued taken the cash flows discount the
cost of capital come up the value of the
operating assets you've dealt with cash
and I will leave it at that right either
at face value or at discount you've
dealt with cross Holdings as best as you
can you get ready to wrap up and then
you take a look at the balance sheet and
you start questioning yourself about
what should I be adding that item how
about that item let's start with the
items you should never be touching you
see Goodwill on a balance
sheet don't add it on right there's
nothing there but let's say you see
brand name on the balance sheet
increasingly European companies
accounting has brought brand name on
should you add brand name onto your
discounted cash flow
valuation what about physical assets
that the company already owns refineries
ships how do you decide what you should
add on and what you should not Lisa help
me out here I valued a company all these
things I'm looking at the balance sheet
what is the rule I use to decide whether
I should be adding something on or not
or just ignoring
it if it's in your cash flows already
you've counted it right that hotel
example that I gave you with the real
estate I can't value a company as a
hotel company and add the real estate on
top of it because I'm double
counting I can't value JP Morgan Chase
and add 277 Park and 270 park or
whatever other they like own like six
buildings in the city I can't add that
on because who's sitting in those
buildings people right Traders Bankers
from whom I'm getting the income and the
cash flows you cannot double count an
asset so what are you looking for are
assets that you haven't counted already
brand name not on the table because
brand name gives you pricing part
margins cash
flows most of the things you see on the
balance sheet you've already counted so
don't start to add things on and this is
one of my fears with fair value
accounting the Temptation is going to be
there right cuz they're going to keep
putting it on so use that rule have I
already counted if you have ignore what
have you not counted
yet well it has to be a truly vacant
asset right you're saying what if I have
piece of land where I expect to build a
factory 5 years from now that's in your
cash flows because you will have less
reinvestment because you own the land
it's got to be a truly vacant asset like
what maybe your CEO likes to collect
picassos
the guy who ran AIG you know 20 years
ago a longtime CEO he liked to buy Fine
Art hang it all over the offices belong
to the
company the problem is how the heck do
you get into the office and check how
many picassos they own but technically
that is a truly vacant asset yeah
TR work it through what do you do with
the trademark
repat is it in your cash flows yeah
right that's the rule right if it's in
your cash flows it's off the
yeah options not if you've counted the
cash flows in
already right you did the cash flows for
the next 10 years tell me did when you
made those projections do you assume
that some of these trademarks and
patterns would be used if you did you
can't bring the real options argument in
yet if you did not count it in that see
the rule then gets passed right you
didn't count it in that's why I said my
always my question always is what have
you already counted in it so I'm going
to give you an example of a truly vacant
asset that's basically a little off
color and off the you know off the
beaten path you know there's a Michael
price Fund in the m in the in the the
mbas have I think you have an analogous
smaller fund the Michael price fund was
seeded about 25 years ago by a guy
called Michael price obviously that's
why it's called the Michael price fund
he just sold his business he had a
mutual fund business to the Japanese of
the boom and he got about $2 billion and
when NYU notices that you have $2
billion God help you right cuz you're
going to get like 50 calls from Deans
and Deans over Deans and Deans on top of
Deans and what are they trying to do get
some of your money they'll make you feel
like you're the center of the universe
they name an entire Plaza after you
maybe bathrooms will be named after you
I don't know what they will
do so they decide know $2 billion
Michael price we're going to approach
and they came to me and said will you go
ask Michael price for some money and I
said not in this universe I don't like
to ask money for universities because I
wouldn't give money to a university
because I know where the money goes it's
not going anywhere
productive they said but please please
can you go ask because we want to see
this fund that MB are going to run and I
said I'll make a onetime exception so I
was part of the team that visited
Michael price we convinced him to give
like 105 million not a huge fund but
that fund is still in place know every
year 10 mbas get picked into this group
they run the fund they pick stalks they
they make pitches to each other I have
zero official involvement with the fund
but almost everybody who's been in that
fund has gone through my
class so when they want to try a pitch
out guess who they tried it on on first
I'm like the target number one I've got
a height cuz somebody said I want to try
a pitch out see if it works so sitting
in my office minding my own bsiness
business when this person who in that
Michael price fund know this like 2008
and N pops into my office guy I never
liked kind of pushy aggressive
guy investment banker from birth I think
basically you know it's kind of built
into his he says I'm facing a conundrum
I very quickly turn to my computer type
in the word conundrum it turns out he
was confused but I like the word I said
what's your conundrum he said my
conundrum is I'm valuing Playboy and I
said I don't see a conundrum yet he said
a valued Playboy at 240 million it's
trading at 300 million I said I don't
see I managed to get the word conundrum
into every sentence I still don't see a
conundrum don't buy the stock and he
said here's my
conundrum there is one big asset that
Playboy owns that I haven't counted as
part of the 240
million you know what he was talking
about don't get your mind in the gutter
right so keep it above board it's not
the clubs it's not the
who is what is it's a mansion if any of
you are from La the Playboy Mansion is
one of the most expensive pieces of real
estate in La it sits on acres of
land worth $150 million and you see what
is conundrum was Playboy technically
owned the mansion that $150 million is
not in the $240 million value he said
can I add it on and I said technically
yes but there's one problem there's an
80-year-old in a bathrob hanging out in
the
Mansion you know who's living in the
Mansion hu Hefner was still living in
the Mansion I don't think with it' be
great PR to throw Hugh Hefner out in the
street right I don't think he owned
anything but bathrobes I think at that
stage he lived in a bathrobe so he said
what should I do I said check the
Actuarial
tables so what am I checking for how
long 80y olds and bathrobes who surround
found themselves with 27y old Playmates
tend to
live stress level heart attack waiting
to have let's say it's 5 years what's
the next
step take the 150 million discounted
back 5 Years be fancy use a CTIC Capital
real estate if you want add it on I
forgot completely about this
conversation go back to my business few
years later I open up the wall three
journal and Playboy pulled off something
and never thought they could they sold
the mansion with Hugh Hefner in it I'm
not kidding this guy Darren Metropolis
buys the Mansion for 250 million and the
condition was that hu hefna would live
in the Mansion till he died and then
Darren could move
in the second this happens think of what
you see on on Playboys balance sheet
what was this asset that never showed up
is now 250 million in
cash that's what you're looking for as a
truly vacant asset things you haven't
counted yet so when you think about what
else should I add on that's basically
the path where you
go so we talked about cash we talked
about cross Holdings we've talked about
whatever else you add on let's make a
pause here and think about now what
makes companies difficult to Value each
of you picked a company some of you even
within your group will have an easier
time than others and to see why that is
let me give you two companies they look
exactly the same in terms of numbers
same growth R same cash flow same return
on Capital so all the financial numbers
look the same but here's where they're
different the first company is in a
single business the second company is in
multiple businesses the first company
has very simple you know very simple
holding structure you see exactly what
they own the second company has created
a very messy holding structure special
purpose entities cross
Holdings the first company is
transparent accounting what does that
mean you read the accounting statements
you you exactly how much money they made
what they own the second company has
opaque
accounting you know what opaque
accounting is you read the financial
statements they claim to be in
English but they really in legal e which
is a version of English that only
lawyers can understand you read 200 Page
you have absolutely no idea what the
company
did so two companies numbers look the
same one is a simple company the other
is a complex company company think like
an investor which of these two companies
would you value more highly the simple
company or the complex
company I would how many of you would
value the the simple company higher okay
how many of you would value the complex
company
higher it's
okay you open up my book and you start
plugging in numbers what's the value
you're going to get for both
companies the numbers are the same cost
same cost of you're going to get the
same
value I'll tell you when this became
something that was topic of conversation
for this class in the late '90s a
company called
Tao had an accounting Scandal and lost
70% of its value I'll tell you what Tao
did it was a conglomerate that grew
through
Acquisitions the accounting Scandal
comes out the accounting Scandal was
they hit a lot of bad stuff under behind
the accounting debris and Goodwill and
restructuring charges whole thing blows
up loses 7 % value but that's not the
story when Tao lost 70% of its value G
lost 15% of its value G at that time was
the most valuable company in the world
he saying why would you punish GE what
did I describe Tao as a conglomerate
that grew through Acquisitions you know
what G was a conglomerate that grew
through Acquisitions investors were
saying we were fooled by Tao because
they used this how do we know G is not
doing this to us
so class somebody says you know clearly
this is an issue at markets we need to
bring complexity into
valuation what should we do and I said
framework is very simple right to bring
complexity evaluation there are two
questions you need to address one is how
do we measure
complexity you can't say I'll know it
when I see it the second is how do you
convert it into something in your
valuation cash flows growth risk
discount rates so I said let's start
thinking so I said I'll come back with a
measure of complexity and I came back
with my first measure and they were not
impressed this was my MBA class I just
counted the number of
pages in The 10K and the 10q and
Incredibly simplistic me ask you a
question if you wanted to avoid a
company in this group as a company you
want to value in a semester which
company you going to avoid like the
plague
1,26 pages to tell me what happened in
one year takes you this isn't war in
peace it takes you a thousand pages to
tell me what happened last year you want
heck of a screwed up
company right and it's by Design what
did City Group do in the previous decade
that led to this the name itself should
have given City group used to be called
City Bank and the group came from
Travelers
group in the late '90s John Reed CEO of
City Bank stood next to Sandy wild who
was the CEO of Travelers group and he
said our objective is to create the
greatest Financial supermarket Market in
history Bank investment Bank you know
real estate company companies often have
these which is fine but this is the side
effect you've created an incredibly
messy company so I show this in my MBA
class my MB look at me and say we're not
paying at that time
150,000 account pages in a 10K or 10K we
want something more sophisticated said
you're right it'll be back yeah
with AI now you can actually create you
can go through text and AI will come
give a give a score of is this fifth
grade
level high school level or is this a
level that nobody even with a PhD can
even understand right so you can
actually come up with complexity scores
at that time we didn't have that so they
said we'd like something more
sophisticated I said what was I thinking
of course I'll be back this is the
advantage of having so Wednesday class I
wasn't back till Monday so I came back
with what I call my valuation
list this is a very it's a it's
obviously a term that's in wide
use I concocted it's all the things that
bug me when I value come don't even try
to read the list it's basically a very
subjective list of all the things that
bug me when I value a company and how
much they bug me I'm capable of turning
anything into a spreadsheet my daughter
when she was looking at colleges was
very
indecisive now this is her General Life
she can't pick between desserts know
colleges of course was this traumatic
exess how the heck do I pick so I
actually built a spreadsheet where I
said no go through she ignore the
spreadsheet completely but I'm capable
of turning anything into a spreadsheet
so I said look you know what are the
things that bug me when I value
companies I I'll give you a few examples
a company that claims to be
geographically Diversified but doesn't
tell you where so why do you bother
telling me you were Diversified or they
tell you where but you don't recognize
any of the parts of the world
they're
listing I still remember doing a
valuation of
BMW long time ago and they have North
America South America Europe then they
Oceania and I'm trying to think back to
my geography class AF where the heck is
Oceania is it like the lost continent of
Atlantis so I called the investment
relations officer BMW said can you tell
me where ocean is he said well it's
Australia New Zealand and Indonesia I
said what do they have in common
he said they buy an ocean I said really
that's your definition of Oceania if I
use that definition 80% of the world is
Oceania what am I left with latva and a
few other landlock
countries but you see by bundling
together Indonesia and Australia you see
the problem they've created what Equity
risk premum do I attach to it because
those are very different risk countries
so I took a list of things that really
bug me how much they bug me and I create
a score the higher the score the more
complex your company
I come back to class and I present this
and say is this better and they say yeah
this is why we came for an
NBA I said there's one small catch here
to get the score for City group what do
I need to
do read 1,26 pages I said I'm not doing
that but each of you has a company to
Value this semester right they could see
the train coming at them down the tracks
too late to get out of the way they said
yes and I said this semester in addition
to valuing your companies I'd like you
to come up with a complexity score for
your company they bitched and they
mourned but what choice do they have
they should have just stuck with my
number of pages that semester is the
only semester I've asked people to
computer they did the complexity scores
but there were some very interesting
findings first they found almost no
correlation in company size and
complexity I assumed that larger company
but there was no correlation small
companies could be complex large
companies could be simple Walmart is a
very simple company paler is a very
messy company second they found that
Emerging Market companies were about 20%
more complex than developed Market
companies primarily because of cross
Holdings a lot of family group
companies third they found that any
company that grew through Acquisitions
was 30 to 40% more
complex than companies or if any of you
are working with companies to do
Acquisitions you're going to run into
this you're going to see items in the
balance sheet like Goodwill items on
income statements like restructuring
charges which throw everything off and
finally they found that any company with
a capital arm a financing arm was about
half 50% more complex than a company
without what am I talking
about GM GMAC Ford Ford Capital
Volkswagen Volkswagen cap capital you
have a bank embedded in a company and
you're told oh trust us with the Chinese
walls around the bank all the debt is in
the bank how the heck do I
know so there were 300 companies that
were that you got complexity scores for
the most complex
company think about all the pieces that
that go into place right first is the
company is in many
businesses there's a financing arm it
goes through Acquisitions if you are
designing a company in a torture chamber
for analyst it would be g g then was in
26 different businesses grw through
Acquisitions it at the highest
complexity score the lowest complexity
score was actually an Indian company
called infosis which at that time it's
completely direct you could read its
income statement you knew exactly so
this notion that Emerging Market
companies have to be more complex is not
true often CFOs hide behind it but it
turned out to be a very simple
company so when you look at your company
and you're pulling your hair out you're
saying I want to punish this company for
being complex for making money life
difficult I'm going to give you a few
ways to do it but you can already see
complexity can come from the outside and
I'll tell you one macro force that has
made every company more
complex you take an annual report from
50 years ago go back and see if you can
pull off something it used be about 20
to 30 pages there used be financial
statements there'll be little statement
from manage pick up the annual report
now the 10K 250 300 Pages why because
accountants are trying to be helpful
every time accountants add layers it
just makes financial statements more
complex more difficult to make sense of
and if you add on additions for ESG
another 100 pages and sustainability
another 50 pages know I call this
disclosure diarrhea where more and more
stuff gets reported and you get less and
less informed as you try to deal with
that yeah was there a correlation
between it was very high so at the end I
said you guys should have stuck with the
number of pages it turns out the number
of pages is actually a very effective
measure of complexity now it's no longer
number of pages because it's sometimes
it's just file size so you can probably
check to see how big the file is and
make your judgment but if you print off
a PDF you can actually see the number of
pages
yeah that's that's a good question which
is why would companies make themselves
more complex if they're going to get
discounted values right first is that
always the case that we discount the
value of complex companies in good times
we ignore it that's the nature of good
times in the 1990s boom times you could
be a complex company I didn't punish you
when do you get aware of complexity is
when things turn bad Chinese companies
are
complex but as long as China is growing
8 9 10% a year you look the other
direction there's too much growth
it's as growth comes down that you start
thinking about complexity because that's
when you worry about it second some
complexity is by Design it's by
management not wanting you know how well
your capital is being deployed right
it's so a lot of family group companies
they build the complexity as a shield
for Outsiders even knowing how the
because if you don't know how the money
is deployed you can't ask questions like
that's a bad investment that's a good
investment so lot of complexity is
self-imposed because people trade off
that control factor for the loss in
value and they're okay with it which
brings me to the final piece if You'
measured complexity how do you bring it
into valuation remember the it
proposition for something to show up in
value what does it have to show up
either in the cash flows or the discount
rate so let's talk about the ways in
which you can bring complexity into the
cash flows one is you can haircut the
cash flows what does it mean if you have
a complex company you take the expected
cash fls and use a lower number it's
completely arbitrary but you say look
I'm going to use 5% lower cash flows
it's not my Preferred Choice but I see
some analysts doing it second you can
try to adjust the discount rate for
complexity use a higher cost of capital
for complex companies and remember I
spent a month on this topic so I was all
I was could try out one of the things I
did during the month was I took the S&P
500 I split it right down the middle
into 250 simple companies and 250 comp
complex companies basically I had to
make some subjective judgments and
remember how we computed the implied
Equity risk Fram you took an know the
the I computed an implied Equity risk
Fram for the two groups the implied cost
of equity for complex companies was
about 1% higher than the implied cost of
equity for simple companies how would I
play that out you can be a complex
company to Value I'll take risk free
rate plus beta times risk premium plus a
complexity 1% pushes up the discount
rate lowest value but my favorite device
for dealing with complexity is you you
think think back to growth what is it
that drives the value of growth what you
earn as a return on Capital relative to
your cost of capital right so when you
have a company that's earning well above
its cost of capital and you assume you
can keep doing it you must understand
the reason they have a return on Capital
that exceeds the cost of capital if I'm
valuing amjet and the return on capital
is 10% higher than the cost of capital
you ask me why what's my answer going to
be what is it about pharmaceutical
companies that allows them to earn more
than their cost of capital
and keep the competition out because
when you earn more than your cost of
capital everybody wants to get in right
so why isn't everybody kind of getting
into the weight loss drug business and
driving no no RK return on Capital to
the cost of
capital there patterns no Eli Lily is
the first breach in the wall because
they've spent the money but it took them
three years to get that there are other
companies that are further back so the
patent is there so I can say that's why
in the late '90s one of the most highly
valued companies highly valued not in
terms of numbers but the number of
people valuing the company was a company
called andron andron is now the stuff of
Legend right to a person every person
who valued andron the 1990s would come
into my office the
question they say I can see this company
makes a lot of money and this was not
even without the accounting Scandal and
stuff what do they
do you know what I never had a clean
answer they called themselves energy
Traders what does that even mean who you
buying the energy from who you selling
it to why are you able to make
money and I never got a clean answer
from anybody in andron in that question
because they said we make a lot of money
trust us and you look at their
financials completely
opaque and every person who came up with
this I said the only thing you can do is
to make the return on Capital go to the
cost of capital very quickly because if
you don't know how they make money how
can you assume they can keep doing
whatever they're doing because it's too
mysterious in the first place if you
truly don't understand why your company
is earning above its cost of capital
then the device to capture that is to
bring those two together and when you
bring them together what happens the
value of growth effectively goes to zero
once you did that andron never looked
undervalued to any of those people which
should have been good in
hindsight final piece uh on that know
I'm getting to the end of the month I
have like two days left in the month I'm
ready to so each of these is is a piece
you can pull off it's somewhere it's on
my web page I try a final trick to see
if complexity matters I took the 100
largest market cap companies in the US I
took their price to book ratios and
later in this class we'll talk about me
price to book the three variables you
used to explain Price to Book ratios are
betas growth and payout I threw them in
there and then I threw in the number of
pages in The 10K into that what is that
minus how would you read that
intuitively what am I telling
you the more pages you have in your 10K
the lower the price in fact I'm going
further every 100 additional pages in
your 10K lowers your Price to Book ratio
by .3 you know what city's Price to Book
ratio was when I did this .9 have a very
simple proposal to double your price to
book ratio what do you need to do knock
off 300 pages from your 10K sounds faes
but if you
simplify you'd be worth I am convinced
that money center Banks today
are being punished because people just
don't understand what they do there's
too much opacity do you really know what
JP Morgan does you thinking there a bank
there Investment Bank they are a Trader
I really don't I mean and and how do I
deal with that when you value Banks
you're not building in those returns and
equity for the long term because you
just is there a fix if Jamie Diamond
called you tonight let's say when you
get home there's a there's a voicemail
from Jamie Diamond saying call me I need
your advice on how to restructure JP
Morgan given that this complexity is
hurting Banks what should Jamie
do you don't have to sell it off spin
off each you can have a JP Morgan
Investment Management a JP Morgan Bank a
JP Morgan I think JP Morgan be worth
more as five separate businesses because
then I can value each business will
Jamie do it not in this universe why
because he likes running an Empire the
largest bank in the world so but I think
Money Center Banks this is increasingly
something to think about so on Monday
when we start up we're going to do the
last few loose cents but you have all
the ammunition you need to do the
valuation of your company so please if
you haven't started tomorrow you get a
nag saying get started with the
spreadsheet hi professor um I got a
question about the
trust loss and Trust regain for the
Facebook story so I think that's a
that's a similar like story happens to
Alaba when back like back in two years
ago like they their men buiness like but
there's another reason the Press
was when you
founded for 12 months and you don't know
where he is that's kind of make people
well I don't know who's running that was
that that job Jack ma the face of very
much part of the story of Alibaba
disappeared and people had no idea who
was making part of itself the
other much of what Alibaba has done
since is not created growing the company
but there a trust I think there are a
couple of reason that trust was lost and
I'm not sure it's fully regained yet
mean Alibaba still looks unded take the
numbers say why is it trading at this
number You could argue that based on the
number of trading there's there's
another Factor among the truck which is
the government is now very
much the big issue there is is the
government Alibaba has ton which is what
the old story was or is it m which is
the post
2009 that's the value I below and that's
what you know Charlie M looking back
said the biggest mistake he made was
buying Alibaba thinking rash and it kept
getting
and also like back to why like CH Monger
like thought that was a mistake it's
like I think he's a he used to think ala
as a tech company but like it turned out
to be a retail company but even that an
advertising yes ad not even a retail
company basically how does it make money
you go
to you see is basically retailers every
time it's more like a paying company you
buy toiss ala get which is a great
business model because very likely
Capital intention but it's also a
business model where you you tiny right
0 one% %. you're dependent on grow
transaction values constantly